he did it he did it this morning we've
been
warning about this for months donald
trump this morning suggested
that the 2020 presidential election be
delayed
he is doing it this is not a dress
rehearsal
this is happening it's not happening yet
i mean he's trying to do it
i get the authoritarian chills when i
read
the tweet donald trump tweeted this
morning
with universal mail in voting not
absentee voting which is good
2020 will be the most inaccurate and
fraudulent election
in history it will be a great
embarrassment to the united states of
america
delay the election until people can
properly
securely and safely vote the president
of the united states is actually
suggesting that
an election which he might lose by
historic margins to joe biden
should be delayed postponed
the president is trying to do the thing
they said obama would do
remember 2012 and 2016 the conspiracy
right
insisted barack obama is a marxist
dictatorial authoritarian nightmare
who is going to declare martial law send
troops to cities and suspend the
election in order to stay
in power indefinitely barack obama was
never going to do any of those things
donald trump has sent armed
paramilitaries to cities around the
united states
and donald trump has now suggested
that the presidential election be
delayed he wants to delay
an election prescribed by the
constitution this is a constitutional
issue
this is a red alert it is no surprise
that today we got the worst gdp numbers
since world war
ii and donald trump's polling continues
to implode and trump says
you know we should look at delaying the
election we have
never had anything like this it's very
attempting to say this is unprecedented
we've never seen any
we have not had anything like this my
hope is that this backfires and trump
loses republican support
i'm right here waiting for the
republicans that call themselves
constitutional conservatives
come out and denounce this i'm waiting
for you make me proud i'm ready
this is actually closing in
on the fascistic characteristics
that they attributed to barack obama
which never existed
we cannot allow this to happen and by
the way how is it safe to open schools
and have teachers and students there for
eight hours a day
but it's not safe to go vote which
depending on where you live takes two
minutes five minutes 10 minutes 15
minutes
and it can be done by mail making that
argument irrelevant
anyway now as a side note trump says
universal mail in voting is bad but
absentee would be okay
this time around all that we're talking
about all that states have done
many states is expand absentee voting to
anybody who wants to do it
it is not some new or different system
that would be rife or open to fraud it
is not that
this is an attack on the foundation of
the country
and an attack on democracy can donald
trump do it well it's actually not up to
him the good news is
uh that it is not up to donald trump to
delay the election
if states wanted to you could delay the
elections somewhat but i think that by
mid-december the electors have to decide
who are their votes going to and if you
don't have
a new president elected on january 21st
again my understanding from speaking to
some
constitutional experts is trump if trump
does if you don't have an election and
trump has not been reelected
on january 20th rather he's no longer
the president and it would go to the
speaker of the house
which would be nancy pelosi which i
can't imagine donald trump wants but
this is going to be a question of do any
governors agree
is there any governor republicans only i
would assume
that will even consider saying i think
trump might be up to something that
makes sense here i think it
we should delay the election or will all
governors say
we're doing the election and that's
basically it now
in the in the coming hours every
republican that is interviewed on
corporate media should be asked
donald trump suggested delaying the
presidential election
do you think that we should do it put
every single one of them on the record
watch some of them start to equivocate
well you know i
i didn't see the tweet i'd have to see
what it is that donald trump wants to do
uh i i can't hear you i think i think
our connection is bad
simple yes or no should we delay the
election
start putting them on record this is not
practice
this is the game this is this word it's
happening right now and he is doing it
and it is absolutely horrifying
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars just for
using their free service at
privacy.com pacman privacy is a service
i've been using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can auto fill the
card number in your web browser
on the phone you can create 12 virtual
cards a month
you can set spending limits freeze them
delete them whenever you want
i especially love it for free trials
where you need to give a credit card
number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cashback rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman